todos los ejercicios de torsión que yo
he hecho hasta el momento en la lista de
física bueno solamente hemos averiguado
la magnitud de una torsión y francamente
porque eso es lo que realmente interesa
pero una torsión es un vector y su
dirección puede ser encontrada ajá
entonces eso se debe se debe a que la
torsión se define como el producto cruz
entre la distancia radial de un eje de
rotación y la fuerza rotacional que se
está aplicando ambos de estos aquí son
vectores entonces bueno vamos a recordar
lo que te enseño yo de vectores la
primera vez y después te mostraré cómo
es o cómo eso es lo mismo que lo que
hicimos aquí con el producto cruz
excepto que ahora am ahora en el
producto cruz además de la magnitud de
torsión también obtenemos la dirección y
bueno cabe mencionar que al menos yo
pienso que esta dirección no es tan
intuitivo ajá no no es muy fácil
comprender pero bueno supongamos que yo
aquí tengo un brazo de palanca y bueno
supongamos que esto puede ser una
manecilla de reloj o algo por el estilo
un pivote y hace rotación
hedor de un objeto y luego bueno ya
cambio aquí de color digamos que hay una
distancia r r donde r es igual a 10 ajá
entonces aquí yo tengo una distancia es
r y la magnitud de r es igual a 10 así
que la magnitud de r es igual a 10 a una
distancia de mi pivote y ok yo aplico
una fuerza f
ajá a la fuerza f la voy a representar
con otro color digamos que amarillo
estaría muy bien entonces yo aplico una
fuerza f quedó algo medio chueco así que
mejor lo hago bien ok entonces esto
estamos que perfecto esta es la fuerza f
en algún ángulo esta es mi fuerza
efe y bueno un vector tiene magnitud y
dirección digamos que esto estos son 10
metros así que digamos que yo aplicó una
fuerza una fuerza no lo sé supongamos
que de 7 newton son que aunque en lo
mejor lo voy a hacer más interesante
digamos que yo aplicó una fuerza
es cuadrada de 3 newtons ajá es más
interesante así y bueno yo pongo este
número porque creo que va a funcionar
así que digamos que el ángulo entre mi
fuerza y mi brazo de palanca que está en
rotación digamos que está en radiales es
de pi sobre 3 y pi sobre 3 si lo quieres
visualizar son 60 grados eso es igual a
theta y bueno basándonos en lo que ya
sabemos sobre momentos o torsión cuál es
la torsión alrededor de este pivote o
cuánta torsión se está está siendo
aplicada por esta fuerza cuando
aprendimos sobre torsión y momentos nos
dimos cuenta que lo único difícil de
este problema es que bueno no
simplemente multiplicamos toda la fuerza
racional desde la distancia del eje
rotacional no debes multiplicar la
componente de fuerza que está haciendo
la rotación entonces la componente de la
fuerza que es perpendicular a este brazo
rotacional baja entonces perpendicular a
este brazo de momento así que la
pregunta es como averiguamos eso
como lo averiguamos cómo vamos a ver eso
como como rey cómo llegamos a ese
resultado bueno la componente de esto de
esta fuerza es perpendicular este brazo
lo puedo dibujar aquí se miraría am algo
así ajá también podría dibujarlo acá
este sería la componente que es
perpendicular este brazo rotacional y la
componente que es paralela sería este
pero sin embargo no nos interesa ese y
no nos interesa porque no está
contribuyendo realmente a la rotación la
única que está contribuyendo a la
rotación es esta componente de la fuerza
y cuál es la magnitud de este vector la
componente del vector efe que es
perpendicular a este brazo entonces
bueno para yo mostrar lo voy a dibujar
aquí abajo un triángulo y bueno aquí
está mi triángulo si este de aquí es
raíz cuadrada de 3 aquí es pi sobre 3
radiales o lo que es lo mismo 60 grados
aquí hay un ángulo recto entonces bueno
aquí es pi sobre 3 cuál es la longitud
de esto aquí tenemos un triángulo de 30
60 y 90 ángulos cierto
y sabemos que la longitud de este es
aunque bueno hay diferentes maneras de
mirarlo pero sabemos trigonometría
entonces usamos la raíz de tres por seno
de pi sobre tres que es lo mismo que
seno de 60 grados entonces raíz de 3 por
lo que es raíz de 3 esto es raíz de 3
sobre 2 eso es igual a seno de pi sobre
3 entonces raíz de 3 por raíz de 3 es
simplemente 3 así que tres medios por lo
tanto la magnitud de este vector fuerza
que es perpendicular la componente que
es perpendicular al trabajo es 3 sobre 2
newtons y ahora podemos averiguar la
magnitud de la torsión es 3 sobre dos
newtons por 10 metros entonces bueno
sabemos que la magnitud de la torsión
aunque seré más cuidadosa que con mi con
mi notación porque la torsión es un
vector aunque usan el término de pseudo
vector porque bueno mejor no entro en
ese detalle pero cuál es la magnitud del
vector torsión bueno pues es 3 sobre 2
newtons
multiplicado por la distancia y bueno
recuerda yo solamente dibuje este vector
para mostrarte la componente yo yo
podría mover el vector hacia acá porque
aquí es donde realmente se está
aplicando la fuerza podrías dibujar este
vector aquí ya que también puedes
trasladar los vectores así que este
también es de 3 sobre 2 newtons quizás
eso lo deje un poco más claro así que 3
sobre 2 newtons por la distancia en la
que en la que se encuentra tu pivote
entonces por 10 metros por lo tanto eso
a que es igual es igual a 15 newtons por
metro entonces bueno por lo tanto esa es
la magnitud de la torsión 15 newtons por
metro
todo lo que hicimos hasta ahora espero
ya sea un poco más familiar a lo que
aprendimos cuando vimos momentos y
torsión pero todo lo que hicimos aquí
fue averiguar la magnitud de la torsión
aunque si queremos saber la dirección
entonces aquí entra el producto cruz y
recordemos la definición de producto
cruz r cruce f
igual a la magnitud del vector r por la
magnitud del vector
efe por el seno del ángulo más pequeño
entre ellos los recuerdas y también está
multiplicado por un vector que es
perpendicular a ambos entonces bueno
todas estas son cantidades escalares por
lo tanto no especifican dirección la
dirección está totalmente especificada
por un vector unitario un vector
unitario es el vector de magnitud 1 que
apunta hacia alguna dirección y bueno
como en el producto cruz aquí tenemos
una parte que nos da magnitud y eso lo
acabamos de calcular usando lo que
sabíamos antes de torsión la magnitud de
nuestro vector fuerza por seno de theta
eso nos dio la componente del vector
fuerza que es perpendicular al brazo
entonces multiplicamos eso por la
magnitud de r así obtuvimos la magnitud
del vector torsión el cual fue 15 y no
voy a poner aquí newtons por metro y su
dirección es el vector en el vector
normal y que sabemos nosotros de este
vector que sabes tú bueno a ver que
sabemos
que es perpendicular a ambos r esto es r
y también es perpendicular a efe
entonces bueno la única manera que yo
puedo visualizar un universo
tridimensional a un vector que es
perpendicular a este a este otro es que
salga o que entre de la página porque
ambos vectores están en el plano donde
yo hago el vídeo entonces un vector que
es perpendicular a la pantalla o donde
sea que tú estés viendo este vídeo y
será perpendicular a ambos vectores
ahora como averiguamos si sale o entra
de la pantalla como lo hacemos bueno ya
lo habíamos dicho usando la regla de la
mano derecha la regla de la mano derecha
tomando a r como nuestro dedo índice a
efe como nuestro dedo medio y la
dirección en la que apunte nuestro dedo
pulgar nos dice la dirección del
producto cruz así que hay que dibujar lo
voy a dibujar por a cambiamos y lo puedo
hacer
prometo poner bastante empeño para que
se parezca a la mano así que bueno este
es mi dedo índice
y puedes como que imaginar a tu mano
sobre la pantalla vale si quieres hazlo
así que este es mi dedo índice
representando a r y también recuerda que
el orden si importa si lo haces con tu
mano izquierda te va a salir al revés
así que recuerda ese gran detalle es con
la mano derecha y mi dedo medio irá en
la dirección del vector
efe hacia acá ese es mi dedo medio que
representa a efe los dos restantes bueno
de hecho te invito a que lo dibujé es
aquí dibujo la uña de mi dedo índice
aquí está y la uña de mi dedo medio así
que haga donde está el pulgar el pulgar
está justamente aquí aquí está está como
saliendo de la pantalla así que bueno
imagínatelo
esta es la uña de mi dedo pulgar aquí
está la palma y aquí está mi brazo
entonces mi dedo índice mi dedo medio mi
dedo pulgar la torsión está apuntando
hacia afuera de la página por lo tanto
la dirección del vector unitario n
saldrá de la página podemos simbolizar
lo con un círculo y un punto en medio
esa fue la anotación que usamos en un
vídeo pasado para simbolizar que sale de
la pantalla y ahí lo tienes ahí lo
tienes el producto cruz aplicado a la
torsión espero haya servido y nos vemos